-Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show," everyone.
You're here, you all made it.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well guys, if you watch MSNBC,
I want to say,
happy Indigenous Peoples' Day.
[ Cheers and applause ]
If you watch Fox News, I want
to say happy Columbus Day.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, 530 years ago,
Columbus went on a trip,
but never made it
to his intended destination.
Today, we call that flying
Southwest Airlines.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, today is also
Canadian Thanksgiving.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, happy Thanksgiving.
It's just like American
Thanksgiving,
except everyone
goes around the table
saying what they're sorry for.
[ Laughter ]
Sorry.
Americans can never have
Thanksgiving on a Monday.
We need at least three days
to digest that meal.
Right?
Let's get to some news.
Over the weekend, former
President Trump held a rally
in Nevada and he tried
to downplay
his classified documents scandal
by bringing up
some former presidents.
Check this out.
-Barack Hussein Obama moved
more than 20 truckloads,
over 33 million pages
of documents,
both classified
and unclassified,
to a poorly-built and
totally unsafe
former furniture store.
Bill Clinton took millions of
documents from the White House
to a former car dealership
in Arkansas
and kept classified recordings
in his sock drawer.
So, we call it the Sock Case.
George H.W. Bush took
millions of documents
to a former bowling alley
and a former Chinese restaurant,
where they combined them.
So, they're in a bowling
alley/Chinese restaurant.
[ Laughter ]
-That's what the Trump robot
at Disney sounds like
when someone spills coffee
on the circuit board.
It's like, [As Trump]
"It's a bowling alley,
but it's not
a Chinese restaurant."
[ Laughter ]
Get this -- according to
a new poll, if the GOP
doesn't win control of Congress
in the midterms,
nearly 40% of Republicans
will blame election fraud.
Yeah, and when they heard
the results, 40% of Republicans
were like,
"That poll was rigged."
[ Laughter ]
Some entertainment news.
"Smile" came in first at the box
office again this past weekend.
And "Lyle, Lyle, Crocodile"
came in second.
Well, apparently the makers
of "Lyle, Lyle, Crocodile"
are trying to pivot to make it
more like "Smile,"
but I'm not sure it works.
Check out the new trailer
I just saw today.
♪♪
-I'm seeing something no one
else can see except for me.
It's smiling at me.
No!
[ Laughter ]
[ Dramatic music plays ]
The worst smile I've ever seen.
[ Laughter ]
[ Screaming ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Okay. Interesting, right?
-Wow.
"Smyle, Smyle, Crocodile."
Well, switching gears, the
U.S. Postal service announced
that it wants to raise stamp
prices from 60 to 63 cents.
And based on the number of
people who still write letters,
that could create up to $10
in new revenue.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, it is the beginning
of the week,
and I thought it'd be
nice to kick things off
with a few words
of encouragement.
It's time for some
"Monday Motivations."
♪♪
-♪ Monday Motivations ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
When Timothee Chalamet
has to cry on camera,
he thinks about
how he's never met you.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That gray hair just fell onto
your head from someone else.
[ Applause ]
You could run a marathon,
but you're so selfless,
you prefer to just cheer
other people on from home.
[ Applause ]
Everyone finishes their popcorn
before the movie starts.
It's what you're supposed to do.
[ Applause ]
You're the hot sibling,
the smart sibling,
and the funny sibling.
And that's not just because
you're the only sibling.
[ Applause ]
It's actually your phone
who's addicted to you.
[ Applause ]
And finally, you've used so many
paper straws that now,
in turtle language,
"Jessica" means God.
We have a great show...